Let us now take
stock and summarize
what we have done for these
two processes, the Bernoulli
and the Poisson process,
and their relation.
The Poisson process
runs in continuous time,
whereas, for the
Bernoulli process,
time is discrete and
is divided into slots.
The Poisson process is defined
by a single parameter, lambda,
which is the intensity
or arrival rate,
and tells us the expected number
of arrivals per unit time.
For the Bernoulli
process, we have, again,
one basic parameter, which
is the probability of success
at any given trial,
or the probability
of an arrival during
each one of the slots.
Based on our model, we were
interested in three kinds
of quantities.
And we found the
distributions of them.
The first quantity is
the number of arrivals
during a certain time interval.
For the discrete case,
the number of arrivals
has a binomial distribution,
whereas for the one Poisson
case, the distribution is that
of a Poisson random variable.
Then we looked at the time
until the first arrival,
or the time between
consecutive arrivals.
For the Bernoulli process,
that distribution is geometric.
For the Poisson process, that
distribution is exponential.
Note that in this
instance, we're
dealing with a discrete
random variable,
but, here, with a
continuous random variable.
And then, as a
generalization, we
could find the time until a kth
arrival, which, in the Poisson
case, is given by an
Erlang distribution.
And for the Bernoulli
case, we developed
one particular formula.
And that formula
is actually known
under the name of the
Pascal distribution.
All of these results,
for the Poisson case,
were obtained because we used
an approximation argument.
That is, we had the results
for the Bernoulli case.
But then we argued that
the Poisson process
is a limiting case of
the Bernoulli process
in which we take time, divide
it into a large number of slots,
during each one of
the slots, however,
we have a small
probability of an arrival.
And this is done in a way so
that the product of these two
numbers stays a constant.
By using a finer and
finer discretization,
we could approach the
Poisson process arbitrarily
close by a Bernoulli process.
And then we used the
Bernoulli formulas
in which we took the limit
as delta was going to zero.
And this gave us the result
for the Poisson case.